[Music]
we got a lot of people here from Los
Angeles I'm gonna talk about something
there's a a cultural phenomenon here in
LA and I'm talking about vanity license
plates you see these when you drive
around they're all there they're all
over the road all over the highways and
these vanity license plates they're
always bragging about something okay
like this one here we saw the other day
5k a day all right even means this
person runs a 5k a day or earns $5,000 a
day or both
either way it's obnoxious all right but
here's the problem I think la is getting
a bad rap because there's also a lot of
very humble vanity license plates out
there I don't know if you've seen them
but I want to prove it right now I went
out and I photographed a bunch of these
humility license plates they're very
down-to-earth they're very humble check
out this first one it's very nice double
chin I also saw this one between an AOL
user clearly this person's not bragging
this next one six push-ups that's not a
lot
check this one out average penis being
very honest till this one in 900 SAT
this one right here 32 triple a bra or
this one this is set adopted and look
beat-up car look at this one net
beyo all right first Curt camp right now
Scott there's one testicle right there
and finally my plate CBS star
and I Drive now a yellow Saturn you do
people think it's a taxi got that to
fall back but I pick them up yeah yeah